[Music]  [Music]  hey please stop bothering like him so  Arthur I have some bad news for you this  is the last time we'll be meeting you  don't listen do you  you just ask the same questions every  week how's your job are you having me  negative thoughts  oh I have my negative thoughts  [Music]  and finally in a world where everyone  thinks they could do my job  check out this guy when I was a little  boy and told people I was gonna be a  comedian everyone laughed at me well no  one's laughing now you can say that  again  [Music]  so positive  for my daily life  I didn't know if I even really existed  but I do  starting to notice  I think this is funny  is a joke to you  very one small thing yeah when you bring  me out can you introduce me as Joker  [Music]  send in the cloud  [Music]  [Music]